[Música]
eu quero que vocês se lembrem de um dia
que vocês estavam passeando pelo centro
da cidade de vocês um local movimentado
com vai vem de pessoas cheio de comércio
quanto às pessoas em situação de rua
vocês encontram por lá já pararam para
pensar como elas sobrevivem quantas
dessas pessoas em situação de rua que
vocês encontram são mulheres
quando eu parei pra pesquisar sobre essa
população logo de cara já me vi nenhum
contexto caótico de informações
para vocês terem uma idéia segundo a
prefeitura de curitiba cidade onde eu
moro o número de habitantes que vivem
nessa situação é de aproximadamente duas
mil e trezentas pessoas pesquisando mais
eu acabei conhecendo o movimento
nacional da população em situação de rua
e descobrir que na verdade o número de
pessoas nessa situação é de 4 mil
pessoas
então a gente não sabe nem ao certo essa
quantidade nem o ibge pode falar isso
pra gente quando a gente está andando
pelo centro da cidade
movidos pelo sentimento de culpa e de
medo a gente tende a ignorar essas
pessoas elas são invisíveis aos nossos
olhos
isso se trata de um ato de desumanidade
ação pra vocês pensarem um pouco a um
ranking que avalia o nível de
solidariedade de 146 países o brasil é
classificado nele na posição de número
75 em 2018 ele foi rebaixado para a
posição de número 122
isso significa que a gente precisa
urgentemente humanizar essa população e
nos humanizar a gente precisa parar pra
pensar que esse grupo heterogéneo que
ele é formado por homens por mulheres
por crianças por famílias
a gente precisa se dar conta
uma pessoa em situação de rua possa ser
uma mulher em situação de rua e que ela
tem necessidades diferentes das de um
homem mulheres em situação de rua é um
assunto raramente discutido e ela tem
problemas particulares só delas como por
exemplo fica grávida e não ter o auxílio
necessário às agressões sexuais que
ocorre freqüentemente e elas também
demonstrou foi um choque pra mim que
caiu essa ficha porque eu como mulher
que meu choro todos os meses nunca havia
parado para pensar que elas também
passam por isso e como elas passam por
isso
então imagine no lugar de uma mulher em
situação de rua
você tá com fome está com frio está com
cólica está menstruada
você só tem a roupa do corpo e acabou de
manchada com sangue
você não tem um banheiro público para
pôr para poder ser um pai muito menos um
absorvente para poder se tratar em 2014
a onu ela declarou que o acesso a
produtos de higiene menstrual era um
caso de saúde pública mundial é um
direito de todas
mesmo assim em muitos países
muitas mulheres ainda sofrem do problema
de pobreza mostrou esse termo se diz
respeito àquelas mulheres que não têm
renda que não tem dinheiro pra tá
comprando produtos de higiene menstrual
preta comprando absorventes e isso não
acontece só com as mulheres em situação
de rua acontece com as mulheres que têm
baixa renda
acontece com as presidiárias acontece
com adolescentes que têm a primeira
menstruação e deixam de freqüentar a
escola por não ter um absorvente ter uma
ideia a mulher passa três mil dias da
sua vida mostrando isso é um gás udn de
10 a 15 mil absorventes
é uma conta que o homem não precisa se
preocupar
é um gasto da mulher ela precisa
calcular o quanto que ela vai gastar com
comida eo quanto ela gastar com produtos
de higiene em 2018 eu fiz um curso que
era de soluções de impacto para o futuro
ele tinha como base de ensino
os 17 objetivos de desenvolvimento
sustentável da onu e foi aí que me
deparei com o primeiro deles era a
erradicação da pobreza
acabar com a pobreza em todos os lugares
de todas as formas e eu comecei a me
perguntar quais eram esses lugares e
quais eram essas formas e com o lema age
local para ter impacto global eu comecei
a procurar a pobreza na cidade de
curitiba e foi aí que eu me deparei com
as pessoas em situação de rua e foi aí
que me deparei com as mulheres em
situação de rua e vi que a pobreza afeta
até o ato de menstruar às mulheres em
situação de rua elas estão em um
contexto extremo
ela não tem um banheiro para poder
utilizá las não tem essa estrutura então
elas precisam ter certa resiliência tá
passando pelo período menstrual
elas acabam improvisando os seus
absorventes com pedaços de tecido com um
papelão e até com sacolas plásticas
foi então que me surgiu a ideia de
reinventar o absorvente de forma que ele
fosse prático e higiênico e universal
a primeira coisa que vem na nossa cabeça
então são uso absolutamente é utilizada
como o coletor de plástico a calcinha
absorvente e até observem de tecido
só que ela não tem um fator muito
importante para estar usando esses
produtos que é o acesso à água limpa
elas não têm como fazer a higienização
deles e no caso do coletor ao não teria
6 onde está descartando o sangue
coletado
outro problema encontrado também foi que
muitas delas nem sequer têm roupas
íntimas
o absorvente externa é o mais comum de
todos ele
assim ela não tem calcinha como ela ia
utilizar então eu decidir repensar o
absorvente interno mas eu queria que ele
não fosse sustentável já que ele vai ser
descartável e foi lá na índia um país
com alto índice de pobreza menstrual que
encontrei uma empresa que está
fabricando absorventes com fibra de
banana como forma de baratear a eles e
eles querem mais sustentável
lá eles estão fazendo então absorvente
externos com a fibra de banana e eu vou
fazer um absorvente interno com a fibra
de banana eu vou fazer um maria
o marília é um absorvente que vem em
formato de rolo tipo de papel higiênico
e ele vem com o intuito de ser
distribuído pelo governo e postos de
saúde e escolas em vários lugares da
cidade
ele funciona assim vai funcionar de
acordo com o fluxo menstrual da mulher
então se ele estiver vindo menor ela vai
destacar um pedaço menor desse rolo ele
estiver vindo maior
ela vai destacar um pedaço maior depois
ela só enrola e está pronto o absorvente
interno ela usa e depois possa pode
descartar no lixo
eu escolhi o nome do projeto de maria
porque eu queria tirar do anonimato
todas essas mulheres são marias em
situação de rua são marias de baixa
renda são maria às presidiárias são
marias que querem frequentar a escola
acabar com a pobreza natural é um passo
adiante na igualdade de gênero
imaginem um mundo onde a mulher ela não
precisa se preocupar com o absorvente
muito menos que a inflação seja um
problema e um tabu
a gente precisa lutar para que as
mulheres consigam freqüentar lugares de
trabalho consigam frequentar escolas
consigam se desenvolver e que o
absorvente não seja um empecilho
a gente precisa lutar para que o acesso
ao produto de higiene menstrual seja um
direito e não um privilégio
obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]